Today's scholars
have unique visions
for their careers.
Cheryl Knott pursues balance
between her work as a professor
and her child care needs.
Rising scholars seek meaningful
mentoring experiences
throughout their careers.
Sangeeta Bathia and Jagesh Shah
are a dual-career academic couple
who both want fulfilling careers.
In response to the needs
of today's scholars,
higher education is
changing to recruit,
retain and develop top talent.
Cheryl: All right.
And think about--we're talking
about allometric scalling...
Cheryl Knott received
her PhD from Harvard
and is an accomplished
researcher in biological anthropology.
Cheryl: I work in a research
station in Borneo
and when I first came,
I was interested in
studying actually human reproduction,
looking into traditional
human populations
but then I decided that--
there's a really interesting
question about what was going on
with reproduction in great apes
and I wanted to see if some of
the things that we were finding,
my adviser was finding out in
humans if those applied to great apes.
Cheryl is also married
and has two children.
So my husband, Tim Laman,
he is a photographer
and he primarily works for
National Geographic Magazine.
And he and I actually met
here in graduate school,
so he got his PhD in the
biology department, in OEB,
and we worked together
in the rain forest.
And he travels quite
a bit in a year,
about four to six months out of
the year I'd say he's gone.
Jessica: Why do I have two forks,
Daddy? I don't need two forks.
Tim: Oops, somehow we got you
two forks. Sorry about that.
So can you pick up Jessica,
or what time does she…
Cheryl: Oh, she--no, she
gets out today at 6:00.
Cheryl: 6:00. So I'll pick her up.
The schedule really is arranged
for when he is gone
because when he's home
we have more flexibility.
I have to adjust my schedule
and like my teaching for example
so that on certain days I have to
leave earlier to pick them up.
Cheryl has responsibilities beyond
research and publishing.
She teaches and advises graduate
and undergraduate students
and runs a research project and
a conservation project in Indonesia
and a REXO lab on campus.
This work takes up
considerable time
and she's concerned about
the number of women
with families that failed to
reach the tenured ranks.
Cheryl says that about
75% of the men
from her graduate program have
gone on to tenure track positions
compared with just
25% of the women.
Which is pretty surprising, really.
You know, they're just some of the
best graduate students in our area,
and the country; and yet,
the women really aren't going
into tenured track jobs.
And you know, why is that?
It's kind of troubling.
Cheryl strives to make
an impact in her field
and be an excellent parent.
But she wonders
if this is possible.
If you have kids--
presumably because you
want to have children,
and so you want to
spend time with them
so it's not just about finding
other people who would
help to care of them,
and that's part of it,
but you want to take
care of them yourself as well.
Cheryl may need to leave
Harvard to get tenure.
She'll also have to
consider child care,
school districts, her
husband's career,
and balancing work and family
before making any decisions.
and how much work can get
done in a certain amount of time
and you know,
it's in the pressure that you're
under to be able to do it all.
I think a lot of junior faculty are
sort of high-achieving people.
And that I think a lot of us also
have high standards for ourselves
as mothers or as parents;
it's challenging then to
be the kind of mother
as well as the kind of
professor you want to be.
I mean something has to change.
We have to make
some accommodations
in order to
make it possible to be a mother
and be on the faculty.
More and more university
administrators
are hearing that child
care arrangements
are make or break policies
for young academics.
Work life issues in general
and child care in particular
is a key driver for
employee engagement
in major workplaces.
We also know that among faculty,
many of them have--
and more women than men
have cited child care difficulties
and other dependent care problems
as impeding their progress
through the tenure track.
And many of them have
strongly considered
leaving Harvard to go elsewhere,
either to another institution
or into private industry.
Cheryl says that she's
never seen a woman
with more than one young child
granted tenure in her department.
Diversity is not just having women
but having mothers, and mothers
of more than one child.
So is that possible?
Can you even be a junior faculty
and have couple of kids and then
get tenure, is that possible?
Situations like Cheryl Knott's
are increasingly common.
Higher education leaders continue
to explore innovative benefits
to assist faculty with children
such as child care scholarships,
research-enabling grants, and
professional travel funds.
Mentoring is something
very conscious,
recognizing that when
you become engaged
with someone--involved with
someone as a teacher
and adviser, you've
got a responsibility.
And your responsibility is more than
just the dates and the requirements.
You want to bring out in
someone who they are,
how they work, and
what they can do best.
To have a senior colleague
ask you how you're doing
and actually mean it and
wait to hear the answer,
is a kind of profound
act of mentorship.
I think that goes
underappreciated.
So much of this was done
informally for so long,
and so much of it was done between
people who had similar backgrounds
and similar experiences
so if we think about the US
academy 75 years ago
or something, it was colleagues
junior and senior were probably
mend from similar backgrounds,
had similar networks, went to similar
schools and these sorts of things.
And now you have a situation
where that's no longer the case.
And I think it makes people
have to actively think about
mentorship in a different way.
It means that you have to somehow
find out who these people are.
Not making the assumption
that you want to turn them into
a mirror image of yourself,
a carbon copy, a clone;
instead, you want to see
how they can be themselves
in an effective manner.
How do you even
talk to a professor
when you try to make a meeting?
Is the best way to
approach a professor
to talk about your interests
and what you want to do with them,
or is it best to talk about
what you think their interest is
based on what their
research areas are;
and how do you bridge
the difference?
I have often felt
that I didn't know
what I could ask for.
For example, I mean I might
be someone who is
somewhat diffident in that way,
in the sense that I
have felt awkward
even asking senior men in my field
for letters of recommendation
when I haven't personally
written a paper with them.
And you know, this is something
that comes seamlessly
to most other people;
I have found that difficult.
I know that a lot of my female
colleagues find the same.
And it is true that
for a lot of the men,
young male colleagues,
my contemporaries,
mentoring appears to
happen more seamlessly.
They don't seem to have to ask
for it quite in the same ways.
And I don't know why that is.
Perhaps the low point of my
being a junior faculty was
that I had worked
hard for months,
many months, to get
that first big grant.
And after a long
and hard struggle,
I did get that first big
grant and I was elated.
And after I found out,
a few hours later
I got a call from my
chairman to come in.
And I thought he was going to pat
me on the back for my good work.
Instead he said, "Richard, it's
great that you got this grant
but you know, this grant
doesn't pay much overhead.
It really doesn't help
the department.
You need to get grants that provide
a lot of overhead to be successful."
It was the worst day I
had as a faculty member.
Mentoring is
important for students,
for younger faculty,
younger colleagues
at the point in which they're
undergoing a change.
They have to recognize
that they are no longer
the recipients alone
of new knowledge,
but that they are now also
sharing it and imparting it.
And it's at that point
that people's outlook and
attitudes are uncertain.
And I think it's at that point
that young colleagues
really need help
as they move now to
the front of a lecture hall,
as they figure out how to take
part in department meetings
and bring new ideas forward.
As a graduate student
I aspired to be a top scientist
in a major research intuition.
I left the academy
for a variety of reasons,
the first of which is that
I felt I wasn't being
intellectually challenged
any longer.
I felt like a very
well-trained pair of hands
and really want to not
work from the neck down
but from the neck up
and use the training that I've
been given as a scientist-
the ability to think critically and
analytically, solve problems...
How do you do mentoring?
Well, you do it formally
and informally.
And a lot has been
said about that.
There's no simple or single way
you can put that badge on
which says "mentor follow me";
it doesn't work that way.
It's something that you
learn through time.
also consciously develop.
Mentoring can be taught.
People who've not done it,
who've not thought about it
can be helped to think
through it in a conscious manner.
Not that there is a single formula,
a single series of things
that everyone must do
but that there are
types of issues,
types of relationships
which you can point to,
which you can bring out.
And for people to recognize
that it's not something
out of sight,
something they can't achieve,
but something that they
can, indeed, learn to do.
Sangeeta: I think it's
how the book works.
Remember what about it used to be--
they used to be that
you would pull on here the little
feet footsteps would come out.
Sangeeta Bathia and Jagesh Shah
are both professors in the sciences,
part of a growing number of
dual-career academic couples.
After beginning their
careers in California,
they had their first child
and decided to move
back to the northeast
to be closer to family.
I was already tenured and
Jagesh was finishing his post doc
so we were both looking
for faculty positions.
And I was hoping to
move and retain my tenure,
and he was hoping to start
in a tenured faculty position.
It's just like any one person making
a big life-changing decision
but it's sort of like squared
because everything is connected
so we have to think
about our family
and the financial piece of it
and where we could buy a home
and where we felt
that we could thrive.
For us it was nice to think that
we would be actually at
different institutions
but were still in the same place
because we could
have our own identities.
We got married to
spend our lives together
and we didn't want to
live in different cities.
So we were just going to move,
if we could, to Boston.
Eventually, they limited their
search to New England.
Harvard and MIT were
at the top of the list
since they had both
trained at HST--
a joint venture between
the two universities.
Well, what was challenging for
us was the different stages
that we were at.
And feeling in our marriage
and as a couple
since we trained together
in graduate school,
we felt like real equals.
Yet, in the outside world
we had staggered our careers.
Sangeeta mentioned her
accompanying spouse
early in the recruitment process
and that she could not
accept a position
unless the outcome was
favorable for both of them.
I think the things that go well
are when you really do feel like
you're an independent candidate.
When you walk in to
somebody's office
and they have a frank academic
conversation with you
about what it's
like at their place,
somehow that makes you feel like
you're a part of the process.
It's ultimately human endeavor so
these other feelings do
creep up, kind of like
"Oh, are they here for me or are
they just giving me a chance
because my wife is a superstar?"
What you wanted to feel was that this
was going to be a welcoming process,
that this is going to
be a process that
where they're going to say,
"Oh, great! There's two of
you, that's even better."
They were willing to work at separate
institutions in the same city.
This flexibility gave them
more options but still,
their recruitment
experience varied widely.
So we had a whole range of offers
that we felt like
were really exciting,
that we were excited about,
where we both really felt valued
and really could thrive in,
all the way to positions
where we really felt like
one offer was reasonable and
the other was just ludicrous.
And you know, those were things
that we walked away from very quickly.
Because they trained there,
they kept in contact
with Harvard and MIT,
and HST wanted to
bring them back.
We had two administrators,
one on each side,
who really championed our cases
and understood we're
independent scientists
who could bring something to the
community that was valuable.
So that really made
all the difference.
Those personally
relationships really ended up
helping us decide to come.
In the end,
they both received
desirable offers
because they were willing to work
at separate institutions.
Meanwhile, their home institution
presented a counteroffer.
But ultimately, they decided
to move closer to family.
It was sort of a
holistic, you know,
what is the life that we wanted to have, not just the job
but the life, you know,
and I had this vision that we would
be close to our families
and that the kids would
know our parents
and that it would be a
village so to speak.
And you know,
that the process was just one part in
what the lives that we wanted to have.
Sangeeta: Yes. Yes, is it 8:00?
Jagesh: It is 8:00.
The demands of a
career in research
science still strain the limits of
Sangeeta and Jagesh's schedule
and they've had to push back,
making careful decisions about
which meetings and conferences
they can attend in order to
spend time with family.
It's not just a
dual career, right?
It's a life together and that
dual career is part of it
and that when you make these
choices about where you want to go
and how you want to accommodate
other aspects of your life,
you really need to take--
it's a whole package.
Finding creative solutions
to the challenges created
by dual-career couples
as well as child care
and mentoring issues
will create a more supportive
working environment
for faculty members.
Developing faculty
early in their careers
is essential to the continued
success of the academy.